[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the cleveland browns will face off with
the kansas city chiefs and their star
center
j.c treader back on the program he's
also the nfl players association
president glad to have you on after the
big win there i was curious when you saw
the uh
the snap by pouncey over ben's head
as a center when do you know that you've
had a snap
that is not going to hit its target uh
usually right away um and and i think
out of
in my career if you go back and listen
to tv copies
i think they've caught me instantly
cussing
the the moment the the play gets uh gets
started because
you know it immediately almost so it's
basically an o bleep
yeah do you apologize to the how long do
you wait to apologize to the quarterback
uh they usually know that the center is
usually pretty upset as
is so i think they usually lay off you
for a little bit and keep their distance
because they know you're pretty uh fired
up yourself
what was your reaction when you saw that
snap
it it's a little funny because it's i
probably every offensive line does it
but
pretty much every first series of the of
the game you kind of sit there and say
man a defense a touchdown would be nice
right now huh
and then all of a sudden the first play
that happened so
uh you know it got a few chuckles out of
the guys on the sidelines because we've
done that almost every game
uh said that before the the first snap
of the game and then it then it happens
and uh
it just gives you a bunch of momentum
kind of a shot in the arm to get that
game started
the 28 to nothing when you're leading 28
to nothing it's still the first quarter
like that's a
i don't know what that feeling's like
because you still have the whole
you know three more quarters and you're
playing pittsburgh in pittsburgh
uh what was that like that feeling yeah
i mean
the first thought is you can't get
complacent you can't
start thinking that that's that's enough
you know how talented they are on on
offense and how talented they are on
defense you got to keep scoring
um and you just got to keep plugging
away understanding that you're off to a
great start but there's still a lot of
time left and they can do a lot of
damage really quickly
but when pittsburgh cuts it to 12. what
are you thinking
uh we got to score uh you knew you had
to put on a drive that's going to
extend the lead push it further ahead
and just give the defense the time i
think
uh if you look back at the time
possession we knew our defense was on
the field
uh the vast majority of that game and we
knew we had to put a drive together a
long one
that gave them a time to rest and
recover and then get back out there to
uh to finish strong
and it may sound strange jc but i did
say this yesterday
without a crowd there if there was a
crowd i don't think pittsburgh falls
behind 28 to nothing
and i just don't know if the crowd
allows them to
it's weird i just felt that that there
was no crowd
it felt like that that neutralized heinz
field for you guys how did it feel
not hearing that crowd that you've
normally heard before
well i think it also impacts the
momentum of the game where
it's without the fans there to kind of
revitalize a team or re-energize the
team
uh the what's happening in the game has
a lot more
impact on the momentum of the game where
when when something goes wrong that the
team itself has to kind of uh straighten
the course
uh and not rely on the the outside
factor the fans getting more involved
and
uh getting the crowd noise up so i think
that definitely impacts it without fans
of the stadium when when something like
that goes wrong
um i think it impacts teams a little
more he's the brown center jc treader
joining us he's also the nfl players
association president
tell me the story about blake hence that
baker said he didn't even know who his
offensive
guard was you know getting ready for the
game
like how's that happen well we we've had
some
some injury issues and some covet issues
in the last couple of weeks
uh we brought some new guys into the uh
into the team and
we haven't been able to really practice
that much so we haven't had much time at
the facility
for the new guys to get used to practice
and get to know everybody
uh so once our our fill and left guard
uh got hurt you know we had to bring in
a guy who was here for
for a week and only practice really one
day with us and
you know he came jogging in i remember
pulling him aside and i was like hey
what don't you know right now like what
are you worried about so i can try to
fill you in these next three minutes
before we have to go out there and keep
playing
um but yeah i think baker said that he
he introduced himself the lock in the
locker room before the game
the first time they actually spoke it's
just kind of a crazy year
how important is practice this time of
the year in person
it depends there's definitely a use for
it when it comes to
keeping your acclimation up and keeping
your your muscles and tendons and
tissues loaded so you don't have soft
tissue injuries you need to be able to
run around
and and cut for that for that reason but
i think there's definitely a benefit
um to keeping guys healthy and having
guys fresh
and there's always that balance of of
what to do now we are forced into kind
of an unscheduled
mini bye week uh and i know when i got
back to the practice field on friday it
was probably the best i've felt this
late in the season
in a long time so there are definitely
benefits too and it's up to the
the coaches to kind of make that balance
of how much rest you give how much
practice you need and now our hand was
forced
uh but i think it definitely uh if you
look at a glass half-fold helped us
starting fast and just playing really
fast what do you think coach stefanski
was like at home in his basement
well i i'm sure a lot of nerves a little
feeling of helplessness
after the first snap probably that those
feelings go away a little bit probably
settles you in
knowing that you get a big play to start
the game but i'm sure it's tough
he's been such a great leader for us all
season uh to not be able to be there and
be
in it and help lead us i'm sure is a
difficult thing to sit back and have to
watch
what's the game plan against kansas city
offensively
well i mean they're super talented uh in
both facets both
their offense and their defense uh i
think
as in any game we have to be able to run
the ball that's kind of been our staple
all year
we have to be able to run the ball keep
the ball
in our possession as much as possible uh
and then we got to be able to protect
the quarterback
and they've got great rushers on that
side of the ball uh just like pittsburgh
did and we have to do a good job of
putting our guys in position to protect
as long as possible as long as baker
needs to make the throws he needs to
make
to keep moving the chains do you find
yourself at all trying to calm him down
baker no for i don't think i could um
but
i think he uh he's been he's been so
great so great for us both as a player
this year and a leader
uh and he's really taken that next step
in both of those departments this entire
year
uh and he's everything you want as on
the sideline as a leader on the field as
a leader in the locker room as a leader
i just don't want him to get into this i
got to match patrick mahomes i don't
want him to get into this ego thing
you guys know your identity and i think
that's the reason why you guys are so
dangerous
is you're a running team and play action
and
can you tell baker i said that jc just
so you remind him
don't try to do anything you know you're
not mahomes
you don't need to be mahomes you can
still beat mahomes
but you got to listen to me okay i'll
let him know but
i think baker knows his his only focus
is winning right now so
i don't think he's worried about stats
or anything like that he's just worried
about what the final score at the end of
the game is and whether the browns have
more points than whoever they're playing
as the nfl players association president
everybody's all in on an extra game next
season
well we already negotiated that i know
but is everybody all in on that that
what what was the vote do you know what
the percentage was of those who said yay
and nay
uh i think it passed by like 60 total
votes right around there
um so it was a tight vote and i know
that was a point of contention was
the the additional game uh but that's
that's what the the majority of the
players voted to pass
with the the gains we made in uh revenue
minimum salaries
um player safety issues so we got gains
back in in exchange for that game and
now we're continuing to work on those
player safety issues
and continue to try to make changes uh
for the betterment of the players health
and well-being even after the cba is
done
i just worry about another couple of
dead games though jc that
don't mean anything and
[Music]
i don't know i i just everybody wants
more
but more is not better here and i know
it gives you guys an extra paycheck but
i
i don't think the quality of play you're
going to have teams that are going to be
clinching in week 15.
and then what do you do with those games
and then what if you're playing a
playoff team like philadelphia did
against washington
those are the things i'm i'm concerned
most about
yeah i think i mean i think that's what
the league has to look at so they
they purchased the option to go to 17
games and they have to make the decision
of when they want to and if they want to
so you know they've already made that
purchase and now uh they have to kind of
make those decisions and look at all the
information of
of what's best for the game of football
itself also they haven't decided yet
they purchased the right to do it but
they haven't decided if they're going to
do it next year right
i think the last the last i've heard is
they've
talked about how they would do it
schedule wise and what they would need
to do but i don't think they've
um officially moved forward with the
17th game as of now
good luck in kansas city and tell baker
that people did believe in the browns
okay
people did and do believe in the browns
oh i hate when players do that okay and
tell him to keep his hat on backwards
as well you know i'm fine with that i
don't have any problem with that okay
that sounds good all right thank you jc
absolutely have a good one
j.c tretter he went to an ivy league
school mclovin